but I absolutely believe that
sexual abuse is probably the the num the
fueling it is the thing that is fueling
all the crime most of the crime I would
say most of the drug use most of the
you know in this country period like I
mean because it's just it's just
something that's so long like the the
aftermath or you know the effects
afterwards are so intense and so um
horrible and like
they have you know it's just it's yeah
and it just lasts forever yeah I mean
it's never it's not just a one-time
thing it's not just you get raped or you
get you know whatever like violated by
this person it's that it changes the
whole outcome of your life I do actually
firmly believe that